-Guys, it is time for
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
♪♪♪♪
-♪♪ Hashtags ♪♪
♪♪ Hashtags ♪♪
♪♪♪♪
-Now, we do this thing
every week where I send ou
a hashtag and ask you guys
to respond to the topic.
So with the debate
happening earlier tonight,
I sent out the hashtag calle
#TheDebateInSixWords.
And asked you guys to summariz
the debate in six words.
So, within minutes,
it was a trending topic,
so thank you so much
for playing along.
It fun.
I love it.
But I thought I'd like to shar
some of my favorite
#TheDebateInSixWords
responses from you guys.
This first one's from
@comrade bot.
[ Chuckles ]
She says, "Thunder dome
in the nursing home."
Yeah, not bad.
[ Laughter ]
I'd watch that movie.
This one's from
@JimJeveryday.
He says, "Originality, clarity
optimism, hope, dreams,
kidding."
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @Stowaway76.
He says, "I kinda miss
Trump being insane."
[ Laughter ]
I'm sure he'll come back.
This one's from @Magzland.
She says, "Did they buy
their suits together?"
[ Laughter ]
They did look like they were
wearing the same suit.
This last one -- This next one's
from @ThoughtsRMyOwn1.
He says,
"12 more days until I sleep.
Oh, yeah.
Well, we're almost there.
We're almost there, buddy.
This one's from @tigervon.
She says, "I'll wait
for the 'SNL' version."
[ Laughter ]
A lot of people --
Yeah, yeah.
A lot of people.
[ Applause ]
A lot of people are.
This one is from @NickyJoWashko.
He says, "This 'Grumpy Old Men
sequel sucks."
[ Laughter ]
"Grumpy Old Men 3: Thunder Dom
in the Nursing Home."
[ Laughter ]
This last one's
from @raisinland.
She says,
"Wonder what the fly's up to."
Yeah!
[ Laughter ]
Probably writing
a tell-all book.
This one's from
@bigdogsjammin.
[ Laughter ]
bigdogsjammin.
She says, "Worst episode
of 'The Bachelorette' ever."
[ Laughter ]
This last one here
is from @JIsNervous.
He says, "Kristen Welker
for President. That's it."
There you go!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Those are
"Tonight Show Hashtags."